let's talk about russia's president
vladimir putin
[Applause]
his decision to invade ukraine has got a
lot of people trying to figure out
what's going through his mind
why he did what he did and what he might
do next it's impossible to know for sure
but if we look back at his life and
career it can help us connect some of
the dots
so here are five things that you need to
know about vladimir putin that help
explain who he is today and how he's
shaped russia
the first thing to know is that putin
started his career in the kgb the secret
intelligence service of the former
soviet union that operated at home and
abroad putin grew up in leningrad now st
petersburg and even as a teenager in the
1960s he wanted to be a spy he first
sort of knocked on the doors of
soviet security services already when he
was in school
and he
was sent away later
putin would say that he'd been inspired
by films and stories he'd heard about
the kgb putin went on to study law at
leningrad state university a stepping
stone for wannabe spies in those days he
graduated in 1975 and finally did join
the kgb where he stayed until the early
90s when the agency dissolved with the
collapse of the soviet union if we think
about what putin carries with him from
his kgb experience
it's
more
that he was influenced by the kind of
thinking
that occurred towards the end of the 80s
where it really wasn't about communist
ideology or
any higher goals it was more about power
and money i would agree with saying that
once again
is all dependent
the gp is a kind of
mafia which operates in that age of the
law
and they do have the principle that ends
justify means and you are not restricted
either by institutions or by laws and
some of the murkier political tactics
that we've seen in russia under putin's
watch come straight out of the old kgb
playbook
like assassinations and poisonings
the murderer koski in a contract style
killing provoked international
condemnation of the kremlin one of
vladimir putin's fiercest critics gunned
down in broad daylight four bullets in
the back in the very shadow of the
kremlin uk inquiry into the death of a
former russian spy in london says
russian president vladimir putin
probably approved the killing of
alexander lidvanyenko now putin has
always brushed off accusations that he's
personally linked to these kinds of
incidents but lots of experts say that
doesn't really stack up given how the
kremlin works any important moves made
by the government or any other state
organization
they are either directly ordered by
putin or allowed by putin now the second
big thing to know about vladimir putin
is how he feels about the collapse of
the soviet union because that's really
affected his world view
it goes back to his time in the kgb
in the mid-80s putin was posted to
dresden in what was then east germany a
soviet satellite state
it's hard to know exactly what he did
because there are different versions of
the story and the kgb was so secretive
but broadly speaking we know that he was
a mid-level officer coordinating between
the kgb and the stasi east germany's
intelligence service
now this was a time when everything was
changing very quickly
back home the soviet union was starting
to unravel
big protests were bringing down several
communist governments in eastern europe
and then in november 1989
the biggest symbol of the cold war
divide between east and west the berlin
wall came down
what followed was a kind of free-for-all
which soon reached dresden protesters
there ransacked the stasi building and
threatened to storm the kgb building
across the street where putin was on
duty he called a soviet army unit nearby
to ask for help but was told we can't do
anything without an order from moscow
and moscow is silent
and that response seems to have haunted
putin ever since
i had the feeling the country no longer
existed that it had disappeared it was
clear the union was ailing and it had a
terminal disease without a cure a
paralysis of power you had this
soviet family young family that
were to an extent privileged by living
in east germany they had to return home
to st petersburg
and
they didn't have anything to return to
for people like putin
who i imagine had his whole career set
on working in the kgb for one of the
world's great superpowers
this must have been a very disorienting
time by december 1991 the soviet union
no longer existed in its place were 15
independent countries including russia
led by president boris yeltsin and later
when putin was president he summed up
what he thought about it allah
it was a chaotic time organized crime
filled the power vacuum left by the
crumbling soviet state
russia suddenly went from having a
highly controlled communist economy to
an economy at the mercy of the free
market
there were some big winners like the
oligarchs a small group of businessmen
who got super rich by securing ownership
of soviet state assets and rock bottom
prices
but for most ordinary russians life was
really hard the economic hardships were
very severe
hyperinflation for two years that wiped
out people's savings
and great uncertainty
about the future so here's the next
thing to know about putin if we think
about what a roller coaster in the 1990s
were in russia putin got a lot of credit
for restoring some order
because after he became president in
2000
things really changed
but first let's rewind and run through
how we got to the top putin's trajectory
to the position of the president of
russian federation was the head of a
rocket when putin got back from east
germany he got a job working for the
mayor of leningrad anatoly subjac who
was his old law professor and putin
developed a reputation for getting
things done it was very effective and
many of my friends businessmen said very
often that it's a pleasure to deal with
him because he is not
this blah blah man he's doing business
within a few years he became deputy
mayor then self-check lost an election
and putin was out of a job he went to
moscow to join president yeltsin's
administration he became deputy chief of
staff
director of the fsb a successor to the
kgb and then yeltsin made putin his
prime minister
a month later a string of apartment
bombings killed around 300 people
the government blamed chechen
separatists but some journalists and
historians have suggested the fsb was
involved
and russia responded by invading
chechnya
putin was seen to be the guy in charge
and his popularity soared
the contrast with president yeltsin was
stark
yeltsin was ill and alcoholic and
unpopular
he was also seen as a puppet of the west
and of the oligarchs on new year's eve
1999 yeltsin stepped down and named
putin acting president
three months later an election made it
official there was a lot of rhetoric
about
bringing back order and stability and
rebuilding the state and indeed the
racketeers from the 1990s the bandits
the killings the contract killings all
this sort of
tapered down putin also went after the
oligarchs suddenly many of them found
themselves charged for things like fraud
and tax evasion
the era of oligarchs
when oligarchs were seen to be
controlling the government was brought
to an end which it was very clear in
terms of who is controlling the
situation and that oligarchs are not
supposed to be part of politics now
around this time in the early years of
putin's presidency the russian economy
started doing really well
the prices of oil and other big russian
exports were rising fast the economy
grew an average of seven percent a year
between 2000 and 2008 and the number of
people living in poverty dropped by more
than half
when the
living standards soar
uh
it's easy to understand why people
thought you know putin was really a
great uh politician
so that's the backdrop to the mid-2000s
putin's in charge he's popular and the
economy is booming and that's when we
start to understand more about putin's
ambitions on the world stage which is
the next thing you need to know
putin wants to restore what he sees as
russia's rightful place in the global
order he's really a man with a mission
he has a dream to build up on the
post-service space
something like
a
modernized unity of former soviet
republics and which will be capable to
defend their interests
and to play a much more serious role
in the international policy the problem
for putin is that many of those former
soviet countries especially in eastern
europe don't share his dream many have
been much keener on joining western
clubs like the eu and nato and putin
sees that as a threat to russia
and his mission
is
his view is that the west is just going
too far and that became obvious around
2004 with the color revolutions these
were popular uprisings across the former
soviet space in places like ukraine and
georgia all of the sudden the kremlin
was seeing the hand of the west trying
to change the governments and that
became quite threatening for the russian
government the first
bell was ringing at the famous munich
conference
in 2007 when this turned to
confrontation started
putin found ways to reassert russia's
power and we saw that in the kremlin's
decisions to invade former soviet
territories like georgia in 2008.
ukraine in 2014 when russia annexed the
crimean peninsula and in ukraine again
this year
these moves seem to have been pretty
popular among russians especially the
annexation of crimea crimea added a
strong sort of legitimacy to this
rhetoric and proved in a way that russia
is strong they saw in him a very
powerful leader who promotes russian
interests abroad who in a way crafts a
sense of belonging to russia in a very
positive way so that people are not
ashamed anymore they were very ashamed
in the 1990s with all the losses and
putin still appears to be popular his
invasion of ukraine in february seems to
have helped too
a recent poll put support for putin at
83 percent
at the end of last year it was in the
60s
but polls are tricky in russia and
plenty of people questioned those
numbers
that's because after more than 20 years
in power putin's established a system of
almost total control
and this is the last thing you need to
know when putin came to power he did
start
to dismantle independent
uh
actors or institutions
and it led finally to the very
personalistic system where there is
putin uh himself and his big apparatus
serving his uh needs putin is
unchallenged politically particularly
you know in recent years where his main
political opponents uh are either in
exile
in jail or death putin's also made sure
he's unchallenged by the russian media
in the early 2000s the kremlin took
control of the big tv stations the main
source of news for most russians and
they could ensure not only that that the
whole kremlin line
uh was always uh spouted off to its
audience but also a cult of personality
around putin was built up and now we see
a russia that is much more insular that
is much more walled off
from foreign sources of information or
even views that are alternatives to the
governments and we also see a president
who seems much more walled off
putin has always surrounded himself with
a close circle of people he trusts
the question is whether or not that's
now got to a point where he's just being
told what he wants to hear or whether
he's even listening at all the system
that was created is a personalized
dictatorship system which went through
rounds and rounds of selection
that brought specific you know yes men
who are around putin now whether that
level of control makes putin stronger
politically or ultimately more
vulnerable is the big question
but it certainly looks like he's
planning to stick around in 2020 he
changed the constitution to allow him to
run for two more consecutive terms
so he could technically be in power
until 2036.
[Music]
one of our recent episodes was shot in
lithuania it's all about nato and what's
happening on its eastern front if you
haven't seen it yet it's right here
remember to subscribe to this channel
too so you don't miss our next one
[Music]